I think the fact that there can be this
exponential warping and it has this
really dramatic implications.
It's pretty important.
It's important for the reason that I
just said which is that it might explain
why mass gales are different.
It could be relevant for other places
where you'd want different math skills
such as inflationary cosmology,
but we also found something else that
was very interesting that you could
actually have an infinite dimension of
space that's an extra dimension of
fourth measure of space that you don't
see and this was really radical in a
sense that since the basically
physicists always thought that if you
head extra dimensions,
they had to be tiny because we don't see
them.
It's pretty intuitive.
If something's really small you don't
see it,
and so the idea that you had very curled
up or finite sized extra dimensions and
that was basically what people thought
was essential for us not to see them.
It turns out that this strong warping
that we discovered could also mean that
gravity is so concentrated that you
don't see it an extra dimension of
space.
So that could have radical implications.
Obviously for it.